j'ai réussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors j'ai décidé de faire quelque chose
parce qu'il ya 2 cédric en ce moment
qu'ils ont la cote
il ya cédric sizaire et cédric villani
photo les cédric et à se connaître mais
ce qu'il ya c'est vrai une ville animée
les cédric est ce qu'on peut lancer le
jingle les séries
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
cédric parce que cédric villani
regardez il ya eu une barque a aussi ce
week end je rappel c'est le gars qui se
présente à la mairie de paris on avait
vu un quantis il a déjà annoncé qu'il
allait se présenter je me présente et
donc la regarde et on lui pose une
question et le gars est complètement à
l'ouest on dirait moi mon frère tu sais
quand au tableau et qu'on te pose une
question et tu cherches fait comme ça
qui va me donner la réponse
on a connu ça c'est un sera totale
regarde un point important c'est que le
prix du mètre carré est en train de
dépasser les dix mille euros à paris
c'est tout simplement incroyable
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
justement éviter que les classes
moyennes les personnes qui ont moins de
ressources ne soit pas obligé de partir
de côté le sujet aussi difficile et
justement les experts comme qui vous
parle d'eux
comment c'est extraordinaire la
complicité des sanctions l'introduction
déjà mis sur la table et beaucoup à
venir faire la peau le coup je me
permets de faire un footing par rapport
à ce cas
c'est d'autant plus terrible qui à paris
de deux questions primes là c'est la
circulation pour une question son
logement à la circulation s'est réglé
sur ceux qui habitent pas à paris sachez
que marie pour faire vingt mètres
il faut compter deux heures en voiture
et une minutes à pied j'avais bien vu
voilà pourquoi là c'est pour ça que vous
marchez de plus en plus cela va changer
l'eau si vous attendez là avec le vrai
qu'il en vo electric 1 entendu wilders
en bas de ce week-end ça va pas arranger
ah oui mais on s'en fout total il est
peut être drôlement fait il est bien
pour un stand up
parce que parmi les décrédibilise
complètement l'action politique c'est
tout rien qu'il est bien pour l'instant
2-1 mais en fait il est grotesque
ah oui il était là en tout cas pour
l'instant je le trouve pathétique c'est
quand même super légers en annonçant
qu'il est complètement illuminée qu'il
est tombé du ciel il un pet au casque on
comprend rien une belle et matic et prix
nobel de mathématiques aims to party que
tu peux faire une carrière politique
c'est de nom mais que tu aimes pas du
diocèse des commandes c'est trop gras
mais il convient veut quand même être
maire de paris donc il peut être quand
même au courant un minimum des sujets
qui concernent les prix nobel de
mathématiques c'est un truc du prix
nobel de mathématiques bien sûr si les
prix nobel de mathématiques c'est
sûrement que c'est un génie et il a un
temps d'adaptation qui est plus long que
les autres mais je pense que ça peut
donner quelques spéciales
je n'essaie pas les gêner comprend là on
est connecté
allez c'est bon attention aux fins de
chroniques ce soir c'est le retour de
l'enquète de baba ça va être le detec en
kit dans la jugulaire 18h57 vous allez
voir mais ça reste un cataclysme ce
qu'on parlera de cyril hanouna qui va
certainement arrêter la télévision oui
vous allez voir dans quelques instants
on en parle à toute enquête alors syrie
c'est vrai que c'est un vrai homme de
2019 par exemple vous écoutez niska en
boucle vous dites pas qu est ce qui se
passe nous dit c'est quoi les buy voilà
pourtant venus de très loin en 2013
deux-tiers choqué quand cav a parlé en
verlan vous ressembliez un prof de lycée
de neuilly à l'époque vous méritiez un
avertissement souvenez vous
[Applaudissements]
après tout les mecs étaient quand même
si vous avez besoin et qui n'aura
chauffeur n'avait pas dit au revoir
si vous êtes à parler verlan mais celle
là ça devient n'importe quoi bientôt
vous allez voir que l'ovale affaire a su
casser ou détesté ça il ya six ans
aujourd'hui vous continuer à lutter
contre ce fléau qu'est le verlan
je voulais absolument la pécho ça me
prend la tête mais de ouf j'essaie de
tout faire pour ignorer aziz est basé
bas je veux pas qu'on aille d'abord
peut-être de proviseur que vous faisiez
quand matthieu delormeau disait un gros
mot maintenant je me fais ni
[Applaudissements]
gauloise et qu'il a toujours les mêmes
occupations pour koné mais j'aimerais à
votre avis est-ce que je reviendrai pas
blond la mauvaise image à ce bourg a
alors glissé alors j'aime bien quand
c'est un petit peu plus blond et d'accès
d'accord allez on fait ça c'est fait la
vaisselle week-end prochain
d'où vient exactement c'est très bien
travers blond vénitien
merci c'est ça qui m'inquiète pas c'est
fait alors ce soir une amitié de trois
ans va prendre fin en benjamins après
vous avoir brisé les codes cette fois
douce et il va vous briser le coeur vous
allez voir si si j'ai retrouvé une
archive de la première émission de
touche pas à mon poste sur france 4 est
manifestement cyril hanouna n'avait pas
une haute opinion de vous ce n'est pas
le seul à vous avoir trahi il regarder
si vous en avez la force sur le pot
sur le tournage de qui peut battre
benjamin castaldi animé par denis
brogniart la production a décidé de
couper une scène dans laquelle benjamin
perdez un test de qi face à un enfant de
ce1 info ou mytho un jour là parce qu'on
trouve ça n'a pas toujours été à dire
que c'est pas toujours été un bon roman
d'amitié qui s'élance comme un oiseau ou
quoi à chaque fois que benji venue dans
l'émission en tant qu'invité expliqué
qu'il voyait pas du tout devenir
chroniqueur en touche pas à mon poste il
expliqué en 2014 qu'une chose ici
obligatoire était rédhibitoire pour lui
vous allez voir quand benji dit non
c'est non
les félicitations tout de suite rideau
sur d8 de carrière était relancé la
gaieté pas si vous vous êtes trompé jean
va mettre une perruque non il va naître
sans perruque
[Musique]
avec
j'ai terminé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu me fait beaucoup de peine à part ça
tout va bien georges cm mais finalement
je regarde pas du tout ça me va bien les
péruviens avec tes yeux tout passion je
pensais ça c'est là la coiffure
attention je suis le pion tpm paix alors
bien entendu je suis là pour surveiller
ceux qui sont ici juste pour faire de la
figuration et ceux qui participent
vraiment à l'émission est donc compter
toutes vos interventions qui a le plus
parlé qui n'a quasiment rien dit la
semaine dernière c'est là évidemment dur
autour de n'oubliez pas de prendre la
parole vraie partie
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette première
édition ne n'oubliez pas de prendre la
parole
le classement qui terrorise tous les
chroniqueurs extrêmement jamais la
semaine dernière le chroniqueur qui a le
moins pris la parole et quel est le
devenir
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon 17 interventions pour kelly
une réaction peut être en neuvième
position celui qui a décidé de faire un
retour très discret françois viot et les
bretons celui-ci deux jours de suite il
a fait plus des missions de jour qu'en
mi temps seulement 20 interventions pour
noah mèche
on a compris que si les revenus ici
c'est juste pour pécho on veut tout de
suite à ceux qui ont le plus parlé dans
l'émission elle arrive en deuxième
position cette semaine
valérie védrine jamais infiniment serena
mais c'est un petit con en première
position de ce classement celui qui n'a
pas oublié de prendre la parole même
s'il a des petits problèmes le français
matthieu delormeau
dans l'émission également les audiences
décollement l'invention cette semaine
avec toujours des prises de paroles très
sympa je suis trouvé une prochaine j'en
ai un merci c'est sympa
[Applaudissements]
chaque son vrai nom chinois 4e et oui il
racontera la fin de l'année sur la photo
françois viot est très réussi c'est
dingue parce que doc gynéco fait toutes
les émissions il est quand même temps
c'est pas fini parce qu'on sait de syrie
depuis neuf ans vous êtes un couteau
suisse un animateur producteur styliste
humoriste mais aussi de plus en plus le
chanteur et selon les médias tunisiens
depuis que vous êtes pris pour freddie
mercury vous songerez y ait de plus en
plus à quitter la télévision pour vous
lancer dans la chanson rumeurs fondées
ou infondées
c'est une nouvelle enquête de baba
[Musique]
lui c'est l'animal
plus connu sous le nom de série d'un
homme nar fall a déjà une semaine que
touche pas à mon poste a commencé sur
les chapeaux de roue pourtant il se
pourrait bien que le vin sans nick lowe
de tunis décide de mettre un terme à sa
carrière d'animateur pour se lancer dans
la chanson
regardez ces images
vous pensez qu'ils chantent pour de rire
pas du tout cyril hanouna se croit déjà
au stade de france
comme à chaque fois qu'il prend le micro
en apprenant la nouvelle franck appietto
patron de sce vite le jour et sosie
vocal de claude alexis la nuit la mouche
sérine tu ne peux pas me laisser tout
seul avec beinheim et berna me suis
quand même le seul gars qui a accepté
d'acheter en jeu de bowling avec lagaf
alors cyril hanouna va-t-il quitter la
télévision pour se lancer dans la
chanson
s'il arrête son successeur sera t'il un
vrai animateur ou bien mathieu delormeau
est il vrai que le nom de scène de cyril
hanouna sera l'oeil dibaba et surtout si
cyril hanouna se lance dans la chanson
fera t-il un duo avec mohamed benyamna
plus connu sous le nom de blue days
[Applaudissements]